on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
i'm peter morgan on censored tonight as
my interview with ukraine's president
zelinski and first lady elena makes
headlines across the world russia
launches a barrage of new missile
strikes including on kiev the city i've
just returned from well tonight i'll
talk to one of america's finest ever
military commanders and a former cia
chief general david petraeus on whether
ukraine can win this war and what he
thinks we should do about putin also
tonight he's the most unsensitive man in
world sporting history cigar chomping
hard drinking golf legend and trump pal
john daly he'll be here live
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening i'm piers morgan
uncensored safely back in london but
sadly that's not the case for the people
left in ukraine there's another barrage
of russian missiles hidden cities
including kiev where i just come back
from tonight we'll bring you reaction to
my interview with the zolensky's and
we'll bring you analysis on the big
question of how
and when can ukraine end this war
but first
[Music]
well everything that you see and hear
tonight is based on the real accounts of
the people involved the shocking true
story of the tv presenter who fainted on
set and the prime ministerial candidate
who almost followed it it was the
mystery collapse
right here in my studio the stunned the
nation and in particular the favorite to
be next tory leader is trust
if he succeeds in ukraine he's not going
to stop that he's going to challenge the
freedom and democracy
well i'm relieved to say that talk tv's
political editor kate mccann is back on
her feet actually she's not she's
sitting down just in case we have
another unfortunate incident okay lovely
to see you alive first of all
thank you piers what have you done to
that studio it's a crime scene you
literally created the crime scene in my
studio uh as you can see uh we've still
got the podium lying here at a shambolic
looking podium uh i'm gonna say i just
got back from ukraine and i was watching
just to see what's the first time you
guys have used my studio i wouldn't go
as smoothly as it normally does and
honestly you were doing so well
and then suddenly bang and i actually
thought one of the lights that crashed
on your head so i was feeling a bit
guilty it was awful and then i realized
no the blame is entirely yours
no quite i know unexpected and as i said
a little bit embarrassing and a little
bit bruised but i hopefully didn't dent
your studio floor i don't think
the worst thing about it is that all the
papers for two days have had massive
pictures of you with health updates on
kate mccann you're becoming a bigger
star than me and that's eating away at
my soul
you've been hating it whilst i'm pleased
to see you it's kind of getting it's
getting me down a bit so can you just
keep a low profile for a day or two um
what a serious okay great to see you and
it was actually it's a very interesting
debate until that happened and that was
a really interesting moment anyway so
well done on a cracking night but
tonight they're out again aren't they
the the two candidates and it seems to
me looking from the outside of this what
you've got is a clear division
amongst the conservatives are going to
decide the fate of these two between how
they view the candidates on the economy
they seem to view
sunac as a preferred candidate on almost
every other traditional conservative
issue they're leaning towards this trust
hence her being favorite and yet the
economy might well end up being to my
mind the most important factor
of any future prime minister given the
way the economy is going
yeah i think you're completely right it
could end up being a real battle between
conservative members heads and hearts
here because
in their heads i think a lot of them
look at liz truss and rishi sunak and
they think well you know liz truss is
talking a really good game here she's
talking about tax cuts but rishi sunak
is the man who's the small c
conservative he's a little bit more
cautious on the economy he's taking a
longer term view he's probably the more
sensible option but in their hearts what
they see when they look at liz trust is
probably a bit more of an exciting
prospect now exciting doesn't always
mean smooth sailing and the party has
opted for boris johnson and that's not
necessarily been an easy couple of years
for them so it's going to be a real
tussle and was talking with adam bolton
just before and he was saying it will
come down to whether conservative
members want to win the next general
election because when you look at the
polling of the general population
most people
do prefer rishi sunak to liz trust now
that could change and polls are just
polls but if they are going off that
then they might be wise to choose rishi
sunek really interesting i mean there's
a lot of time left in this race this
trust ahead at the moment if you were
advising rishi sunak what's he gonna do
well i think we've seen what some of his
advisers must have told him to do in the
debate so far which was be more punchy
he's been really determined he's been
talking over liz trust
sometimes actually to the point where
you really can't even hear what she's
saying and that's gone two ways with
some members they really haven't liked
it they've accused him of mansplaining
liz trust his own camp has said that but
for others i think that the calculation
has been that maybe this was the side
that he needed to show that he had a bit
of spunk something about him and he
wasn't just the conservative chancellor
former chancellor
i think it's really difficult for him
now at these hustings tonight they've
both gone very hard on having northern
roots being the person to take forward
the northern powerhouse leveling up but
i just don't know whether that's going
to be enough for him in this race with
tory members and as i say i think it
will come down over the next couple of
days to that head versus heart decision
and the ballot papers remember will go
out over the next week or so and many
members will make their choice early so
although this contest does have a few
more weeks to run it could well be over
quicker than we think one of the more
selfish uh thoughts i had the other
night was that you were literally about
to ask both candidates about the moment
from my zelinsky interview i won where
he talks about the two candidates and
it's an interesting question where the
president of ukraine admits he's very
worried about what comes after his great
friend boris johnson who's been such a
great supporter to say being in ukraine
for a few days they love boris johnson
over there i think he's been a
tremendous supporter and it's an
interesting question for them because he
wants to get and clearly this war could
be raging even more ferociously by the
time they take over as pm he wants to
get a feeling zolensky whoever follows
boris will be as supportive if not more
so on that on that
issue who do you think is more likely to
be the more supportive or are they the
same
yeah it would have been such a powerful
question because neither of them would
have known that it was coming and they
would have had to have thought of their
answer just right there in the studio so
it's such a shame i didn't get to ask it
but i think it would have been really
difficult for rishi sunak to navigate
because his whole promise is that he's
going to be economically very careful
and remember the conversation had been
throughout that debate about bills about
pressure and about the fact that people
couldn't afford their shopping and we
were coming on to talk about energy
bills and that's something so closely
linked to ukraine and there has been
some conversation if you like about if
the uk government is going to continue
to support ukraine about the impact
that's going to have on everybody and
how the government keeps the country
with that fight if you like now liz
trust i think has a pretty strong answer
here she's been closer to that issue as
foreign secretary she's also been quite
determined from the very start to throw
her weight behind the ukrainians so
perhaps she may well have edged it in
that answer i think in reality both of
them are very determined to keep that
level of support up but potentially
wishy sunak understands the impact that
it will have on families a bit more and
knows how much it's going to take to try
and offset that yeah okay it's great to
see you and we've got a little little
tribute to you really so it's a
brilliant song by chawamba womba
remember this
yes i remember this song
it's great to see you good to see you
back on your feet what nearly
nearly
good to see you kate all the best thank
you you're bound from the studio we're
good to see you
well it might want us to do the
interview with president zolensky uh he
urged president biden to visit ukraine
to send the seat the strongest signal of
support that he could have on census
next to discuss
what he said there and how the rest of
the world can support ukraine to end
this general david petraeus and
ukrainian mp kirari
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well we've been bringing a special
coverage of ukraine's war from kiev it
was an extraordinary journey into a
country on high alert i met some
remarkable people suffering untold agony
at the hands of putin's invaders also
met some very inspiring people in the
country whose brave unwavering
resistance has rallied the world one man
has symbolized and inspired that
resistance above all others president
zlenski and on the last side show we
brought you my world exclusive interview
with the president and the first lady
elena zelensky it's been making
headlines across the world and here's a
reminder of why
thank you for the interview
this interview is one of the good
opportunities for us to see each other
these kind of situations they can make
or break your marriage i have to begin
to answer
okay
okay
sometimes we i i can see smile
and and also i i have this
minutes for smiling i think it helps
helps very much the most important thing
is not to have divorces every week that
we are managing
we are managing
yes we are managing is not the right
word
we are in love with each other okay okay
okay will you ever
contemplate
doing any kind of deal
we are not prepared to exchange or trade
the territory of the independent state
of ukraine what is your
view of vladimir putin it seems to me
the scariest thing about it is that he
is in fact sane and he understands what
he's doing are you worried that boris
johnson is now
going to be leaving downing street
leaving his house
to be honest i am worried about it
president biden hasn't been to ukraine
yet have you invited him
yes you have yeah
are you hopeful he'll come i don't know
that his choice i think if he'll have
any possibilities he will come
well
he forgot
he forgot
you forgot to tell your wife you're
running for president you found that on
tv
mr president
really you you announced it on
television
[Music]
i was not laughing so much so loud
well just hours after the interview
aired a stark reminder of the realities
of this war indiscriminate russian
bombing more than 25 missiles far from
belarus across ukraine including areas
around kieva hadn't been struck for four
weeks rockets raining down on civilian
infrastructure
in this garage a small city just 12 and
a half miles from where i was staying
and very near where we did some filming
in fact and the military base in li
youtu
which is just 20 miles from city centre
all of ukraine of course is a war zone
when pewter can fire missiles more than
a thousand miles and nobody's safe and
nobody will be safe until putin's war is
over so how do we stop him we're joining
me now is the former cia director and
top military commander general david
petraeus uh general thank you so much
for joining me i can't think of a better
person actually that i'd like to talk
about this with than you i've just spent
a few days in ukraine in kiev uh i met
with president zielenski had a long
interview with him and my overriding
sense was that both the people and the
president are utterly determined not to
concede one inch of territory to
vladimir putin and yet the harsh reality
on the ground is that putin is taking
slowly but surely and in a devastatingly
brutal manner more territory so i guess
my question for you with all your
military expertise is what is what is
that reality on the ground from where
you're looking
well it's a very very hard reality uh
with very significant casualties uh very
substantial rates of indirect fire from
russia as you know what they have
resorted to is
what they did in chechnya and grozny
what they did in aleppo which is
essentially just destroy
a location when it put up resistance to
rubble it and then to take over that
rubble but what has happened in the past
week or two i think has been quite
significant and that is that there's
been a reduction a very significant
reduction
in the rate of fire by russian indirect
artillery uh by their missiles by
rockets and so forth uh and even though
you have you do see periodically missile
strikes that are across the country as
you reported uh the rate of fire on the
front lines particularly in the area
where russia is trying to advance now
and donetsk oblast or province
is dramatically reduced and we believe
that is from the
just basically exhausting the ammunition
supplies by no means completely but
dramatically reducing the supplies of
artillery rocket and missiles
that the russians have and then second
the increasing success by the ukrainians
and taking out the ammo supply points as
well as the fuel depots and headquarters
of ukrainian for of russian forces with
uh the ukrainian multiple launch rocket
systems again the ones that have been
provided by the united states in
particular
uh also by the enormous quantity of
artillery uh heavy artillery pieces and
ammunition you know just to keep this in
perspective
the u.s has committed up to 410 000
rounds of 155 millimeter howitzer
ammunition that's heavy artillery just
to transport this with standard 5 ton
trucks could be as many as 12 000 13 000
individual trucks depending on how
you're able to pack them that is a
staggering quantity that's just the
ammunition for the 155 millimeter
howitzers that doesn't include the the
rockets all the other uh ammunition and
systems that are being provided and
that's just from the united states
noting that of course uh the uk germany
many other countries have provided
substantial amounts as well and i should
just note here since you know we're on
is a british show
the uk has really walked point in many
respects for the support of ukraine
since the very beginning the uk was the
first to fly in anti-tank guided
missiles the us was the uk was the first
with anti-ship missiles the first uh
senior leader of a major nato country to
visit uh and of course he visited twice
as i recall and then even visited of
course uh finland uh again to reassure
them as the wheels were turning for uh
the notification that finland and sweden
would be uh invited to join nato so
again i understand the concerns that
president zielinski voiced although i
would also say having
always been the
a great believer in this special
relationship between the u.s and the uk
that this kind of support will continue
regardless of who is elected prime
minister but pierce if i could the real
uh
area on which we should focus right now
is actually the southern part of the
country
uh the southeastern part where the
russians did take control of all of
luhansk oblast and where they're trying
to take more control of donuts that
offensive is really slowing it was
always a grindly costly affair but it is
now
really slowing down and where we should
focus is in the south
particularly in hair salon that's
k-h-e-r-s-o-n that was the first
major city in the first entire uh
province that was taken
by russia coming right out of crimea in
the beginning of the war
and ukraine has been on the counter
offense they've been setting the
conditions if you will to use a military
term
for a full-on offense of there to retake
to liberate harrison city which is a
major
uh i mean general what you're doing if i
may just just jump in there you what
you're doing you're you're training
you're painting a more optimistic
picture than i anticipated it is your
belief that ukraine as as president
president
assured me is your belief that they
could win this war and and if so what
more should the west be doing to help
them do that
first of all as i used to say during the
surge in iraq i'm neither an optimist or
a pessimist i'm a realist
the reality i think on the battlefield
there is that ukraine has finally been
able to be just really to begin to
absorb
this massive quantity of arms and
ammunition provided most significantly
by the united states but also again by
the uk and other major nato and other
western uh countries around the world
and again that takes a lot of time we
had to train them on this multiple
launch rocket system the high mobility
rocket system highmars that we have
provided now we're up to 16 of them now
you say what more could we do i'd park
30 of them in eastern poland and say
come get them when you're ready as
opposed to sort of meteoring them out
but but again that's a that's a minor
point compared to the massive support
that the united states has provided and
the u.s leadership really of
nato
and
the transatlantic relationship in the
entire world in providing
this very very solid support to
ukraine should president biden be going
up should president biden be going to
ukraine as president zielanski has asked
him to do as a as a symbol
you know i'm a bit torn on that honestly
uh you're gonna put the president of the
united states you know the world's
iranian superpower if you will fly him
in put him on a train you know ride and
put him uh at risk of those missiles
that you reported landed 20 miles from
you i i don't know i can understand why
the secret service and others would have
a very dim view of that perhaps a
meeting in western uh ukraine at some
point might be in fact as i recall
president biden's wife did
go inside there and meet uh out in the
very western portion the president of
course has been
to europe a number of occasions uh and
made a visit to poland and a very strong
speech there uh as well as you will
recall yeah uh but by and large what has
been provided by the us in terms of it's
just sheer leadership and then the
support in terms of money uh arms
ammunition and so forth is now enabling
ukraine i think for the first time
to stop being on the defense and
actually go on the offense and i think
the place to watch again is here son the
ukrainians have been against setting
conditions by that i mean they're
painstakingly destroying yeah with these
precise multiple launch rocket systems
and the precision artillery as well some
of these rounds we've provided over a
thousand of the rounds are cost 110 000
each because of the precision and the
additional range that they can provide
and they've been they've been destroying
the headquarters ammo supply points
fueled uh depots uh and other major
logistical nodes uh for the russians and
the russians have had to withdraw these
nodes out of that range keep in mind
that it's as much as 70 to 75 kilometers
for the uh advanced rockets
general i have to unfortunately i have
to leave it there uh it's fascinating
what you've just told me about all this
it's a brilliant analysis of a very
complex situation over there and i
greatly appreciate you joining me i hope
that your sort of green shoots of of
recovery by the ukrainians against this
russian surge uh come to fruition
because it would be a major step forward
thank you general petraeus very much
indeed for joining me great to be with
you pierce thanks
well joining me now in the studio is
kiera rudik is ukrainian member of
parliament leader of the opposition
great to see you you're in the uk as
you've been going around trying to rally
support obviously are you encouraged by
what general petraeus said he's one of
the great commanders of modern times for
the american military and he was quite
encouraging i think there about some of
the gains that ukraine may be about to
make
um i actually agree with what the
general said
and this is something that we feel and
we plan as well
i think till the beginning of winter
when any military attempts will be very
complicated both for ukrainians and for
russians we would want to take back our
southern territories not sure about the
east but right now when we are finally
getting enough of the
nato grade uh weapons we are um taking
our territories back i mean everybody
knowing right now how effective our
forces can be i mean what was i was
struck by over in kiev was just
everybody i talked to
was utterly the moment i mentioned
giving up any territory to the russians
no no no no no everyone you cannot too
much blood has been shed too much
murderer mayhem has been uh caused to
the people and president zolansky agreed
with this
other experts who've been involved in
many conflicts say it's almost
inevitable that the way this eventually
ends is with russia being able to keep
some of this territory what do you think
why
should we as a sovereign country who
didn't do any harm
should right now give up our terrorists
well i agree with you yeah but you think
it's inevitable they may have to no
i do not think that i think we will be
fighting till the end and if we will get
enough of the support with money
sanctions and weapons we will be able to
take those territories you see right now
by the fact by the recent events that we
are able to so that would be not the
question to us because our resolve is
consistent that will be a question to
our allies to the united states to you
guys in the united kingdom of how long
and how much we will be getting of
everything that we will need to fight
this war because if we will have to give
up our territories then it will mean
that if you have nuclear weapons if you
have putin you can do whatever you can
do whatever you want i totally agree a
western world will
what he wants he keeps bullying exactly
i totally agree with that
there was a famous picture that came out
of you uh taking up arms uh like so many
people in ukraine ready to fight the
fight we're looking at that picture
there now this is a country that will
fight to the death to save its its
freedom and democracy
we will be fighting till the end
we all made this decision on the first
day of war and right now every single
morning it's just you're asking yourself
what can i do so the victory will be
closer where am i the most effective
what am i doing today so that we will be
able to end this war as soon as possible
without giving any of our territories
without uh falling down to putin when i
was in kiev a few air raid sirens went
off but there hadn't been a missile
strike in a month
and we were fortunate nothing happened
when i was there almost the moment i've
got back overnight a barrage of missiles
fired from belarus all over uh ukraine
including kiev itself
people there live in this constant fear
that they they could be the next
target of these missiles it's it's an
awful condition for human beings to live
in
you know like when you hear airy sirens
it's just like on the natural level you
were thinking
somebody will die yes and this is
actually terrifying because there is
nowhere in ukraine where you can feel
safe and you can know like how your day
will end you wake up you go to have some
coffee with your friends and then you
don't know like what's going to happen
next and it is terrifying and this is
why we are not only asking for the
offense uh weapons we are also asking uh
the way to close our skies so we can say
oh there are some territories in ukraine
you're the opposition leader but
president zolensky has been getting a
lot of plaudits around the world for his
leadership are you impressed by what
he's done in this war
of course and
right now we are not talking about us as
politicians as coalition opposition we
are all team ukraine and we are all
acting as one because now we know that
it's a huge luxury to have the political
debate to be able to uh to
talk and argue about things because
right now we have only one goal and it's
a mutual goal and this to win this war
yeah after that we'll be able to you
know go back to our normal life
we hope that they will what's the thing
when this is all over which it will be
one day what's the thing you're most
looking forward to doing again in normal
life
having dinner on my backyard with my
family without knowing that we'll have
to go to the basement any minute
i think that says it all thank you so
much for coming in today and best of
luck to you and all your people i i
found the spirit of the ukrainian people
magnificent you remind me of the british
in world war ii when the germans were
bombing us they will not win and i love
that spirit about you so thank you thank
you and glory to ukraine slavi
slava nice to see you all the best well
i'm sensitive next tonight's pierce back
to krakow aventina and all the way from
america and coulter is live in my lair
anything could happen here it's gonna
get fiery join us after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
you know when i was in kiev in ukraine i
was there to moderate the first lady's
summit of first ladies and gentlemen and
in the middle of it a guy came on in
combat fatigues i assume he was military
it turned out he wasn't at all his name
is fedor uh shandor fedia schandel he's
the head of a sociology faculty at a
university in kiev and a historian he's
with the territorial defense and the
haku region and he actually has gone in
and enlisted to fight on the front line
he came back from the front line to talk
of the summit here was me talking to
about the summit when i discovered this
i don't think i've i've ever interviewed
anybody who sits on a panel one minute
and literally is going back to trenches
to fight for his country it's an amazing
thing my duty and peaceful time to teach
my main line of duty in the war time my
line of duty is protecting my family and
my
nation
thank you
it's amazing
well it was amazing and then even more
amazingly i got this video from him back
on the front line take a look
hello peers
uh today is
24 july
it's my soldier's brother helped him
organo appears is blind
maybe three four kilometer of uh zero
line deadline uh slaviansk uh
region
hello nice to meet you
the guy is a university lecturer isn't
that incredible
out there fighting risk country uh very
close to the front line there so to
feder shandor and your guys in that
trench best of luck to you we're all
behind you well joining me now is
tonight's pierce back talk tv
contributor esther cracker political
journalist avers and tina and social and
political commentator i mean that's a
polite way of putting it ann coulter
welcome to all of you i was called to
welcome across the pond what brings you
to this country and why wasn't i warned
i thought i'd stage a sneak attack on
you and here i am uh no i love london
i'm so happy here it's a beautiful city
please take care of it let me ask you
about ukraine because there is you know
there's a growing sentiment in america
that with recession
really pretty much here now surging
living costs and so on that america
shouldn't be committing so much money to
helping fight a war which some americans
feel with them zalensky's answer to that
was actually this is a war everyone is
involved in it's affecting everybody
what's your view
um i don't think so i mean you're not
going to like my answer but that was my
position from the beginning in the world
that's very rarely like anything that
comes out of your mind
oh it is definitely moving that
direction it wasn't at first it was just
you know endless endless coverage for
this i mean there are a lot of things i
could say about this going back to
i mean i think putin is a monster you
don't go around invading other countries
but we didn't provoke him putin has been
reaching out to america he was the first
person to call after 9 11 to express his
condolences to america and bush doesn't
even call him back we've just so dissed
the russians for such a long time and
the nato thing i'm sorry i'm with noam
chomsky pat buchanan george cannon once
the soviet union fell there's no point
to nato and we keep encroaching
encroaching actually we're now seeing
exactly what the point of nature is well
you could stop a murderer
that's what nato is there for no if he
tries to invade a nato country he will
get it it's not a nato country he
doesn't want to become a nato country
and no i'm sorry the ukraine was
historically part of the russian empire
of influence and i'm not defending
including the soviet union
no i am not what are you saying but why
let's get back to the main point why
should americans care about this we have
our own problems why should the british
care about it i mean you guys well i
don't need i think it's a beautiful city
and i hope you save it but you've just
passed brexit a huge part of which was
this is the same reason when we have
more immigrants coming in i'm so glad
pivots
boris is gone right and hopefully the
next one will actually fulfill the
promises of brexit but how about
something [ __ ] if i could get a word
in edgeways it'd be appreciated here's
my point to you when we were attacked by
the nazis and when this city was
attacked in the way that uh ukraine's
leaders being attacked actually the
americans when you were attacked to
pearl harbor realized it was a world war
and you came and helped us win the war
and defeat nazis or would always speak
in german and that's the reason why when
you have a massive war in europe like
this which is the biggest since world
war ii that's why we should come
together and america whether you like it
or not biggest superpower in the world
we need your help ukraine needs your
help you can't compare everything to
hitler
okay can't compare people
okay
pearl harbor i'll i'll be interested but
he's not attacking the united states
you've been listening to this with
calmness well no i don't know i think
you were just talking quite a lot of
tripe actually but i mean that's that's
your your thing and
you know when you talk about um russia
not you know putin not actually
affecting the rest of the world it's
nothing to do with america it's nothing
to do with britain britain right now is
facing a huge crisis in terms of grain
we physically can't get wheat into the
country this winter we're looking at our
energy bills are going to be something
like 500 pounds a month it does affect
us it directly does affect us but you
know we talk about globalization most of
your products probably half of what
you're wearing has come from different
parts of the world it's totally obscene
to think that we're going to go back to
some sort of like you know fdr like why
not
what's going on in swaziland a lot of
countries are having a lot of problems
and not all of your energy problems or
grain problems are coming from the
invasion you know you are your interview
with him i mean i think the most
disturbing point was i'm glad you asked
him are you willing to give up anything
here and no his position is why should
they give up anything because what he
was going to find
somebody invaded the united states if
someone invite invaded america any part
of america right you're telling me that
a single american would say oh yeah
we'll give them a bit of land whoever it
is oh you would you would come together
and drive them out of your country okay
by the way you'd want us to help you
okay could we google something russia
has what 50 times more people than
ukraine you've got to end this war or
it's going to be down to the last youth
i'm really speechless but i think in
this instance i'm quite speechless i
think the
international repercussions of what is
happening in ukraine cannot be
understated at the moment the russian
foreign minister is in africa because he
realizes that you know people have
forgotten this but many africans are
dying with the rising cost of energy and
wheat for instance egypt which is the
largest importer of wheat the price of
wheat has gone up by 250
i think it's irresponsible to think that
what is happening in ukraine isn't
affecting everyone including americans
and it's only going to get worse i mean
look the us is trying to find a way
around that um at the moment but i i
just don't understand how you can think
that's this is not an american problem
it clearly is and he's not going to stop
at ukraine moldova is next then
lithuania then estonia then latvia do
you give it all back to him if he wants
he must have stole the soviet union
help yourself far more preposterous than
the idea that he's going to
forget pearl harbor that he's going to
continue okay when he continues maybe
maybe we care but you know what else
affects the rest of the world whether
the united states america of america
remains the united states of america why
don't you guys come over and help us
build our wall why don't you help us
deal with crime because you're right we
do step in we we send grain food we take
out warlords i mean you guys do too but
america is mostly a force for good in
the entire world and our country is
crumbling right now so yes everything
has an effect i'm not saying there's no
effect and you can make your six degrees
of separation saving the united states
of america i think saving britain is
more important than what is happening in
rwanda swaziland or ukraine
okay let's move on to the issue of the
tour leadership race because actually
whoever wins this race is going to have
to make these kind of calculations and
there will be people in this country who
also think we shouldn't be spending a
lot of money on a war in ukraine when we
have so many problems here and they may
not do the the points of detail which
bring the things together and connect
connect the dots here from what you've
seen with liz trust and richie sunny who
do you trust more of the two of them one
of them will be prime minister to
actually do the right calls on this kind
of thing whichever one employs ben
wallace as their defense secretary i
think he's the only one who's actually
been holding it together i don't think
either of them have got a clue i don't
think there's ukraine much disagreement
there i don't see any of them sort of
getting rid of ben wallace um but i
think it's clear that rishi sunak's
campaign is in free fall and i think the
biggest issue he's had has been
communication
boris said a cheeky made a cheeky remark
today that he suddenly found the money
to
cut vat on energy bills which he
actually refused to do beforehand and he
hasn't really explained sort of his
stance on
it's kind of flip-flopping yeah it's
gonna be it's look we've got five weeks
left
uh i'm actually off from today i'll be
back on the day they announced the new
prime minister and i would say at the
moment this trust is playing a better
political game yeah that rishi's saying
that probably assumed he's going to win
this quite easily not so easy now at all
but it's two trades of the same color
right right do you care who wins that or
not um yes esther told me who's the guy
i like rees-mogg yeah oh my god whatever
he's all right
you know what there's always a low
moment with ankle for an interview we've
just reached it wonderful from a very
low bar by the way uh it's good to see
you and you know thank you as always
you've rattled everybody's cage viewed
tomorrow
really good to see well i said next is
one of my most favorite sporting legends
i'm not afraid to speak his mind
two-time major winner john daly
is here one of the most charismatic
figures a world sporting history there
he is look at him magnificent we'll be
mr daley in a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well this week is big news in the world
of gold saudi fronted live golf tour
heads to the trump national golf club in
new jersey tom's been accused of helping
to sanitize saudi arabia's international
image and 9 11 families united group
have eviscerated both the defected
golfers and the former president trump
for taking part but joining me now is
john daly a two-time major golf winner
trump friend and supporter and a great
character john daly what a pleasure to
have you on my show
thanks for having me pierce i love you
brother
thank you i love you brother too you
know there was a moment at the open in
scotland when you were walking past i
think you were wearing your hooters
trousers and i shouted your name
and you suddenly turned you didn't know
it was me you just turned and looked to
the group of people and you gave us a
hilarious smirk and a great wave and we
all just melted in awe at this great man
doing his thing
well
i love my fans man i've always loved him
i've always played for him and
you know wherever i've gone in the world
to play golf i've always had a home team
advantage and it's been awesome
for 30 something years it's just been
great
well you deserve it because you give a
lot back to the fans i think and also
you play golf the way i play which is
you know have a beer have a game of golf
have a cigar maybe have a bit of fun
smile on your face but right now john
golf is going through a very difficult
fractious period between the official
pga tour and this rival live tour funded
by the saudis it's now come to uh
trump's cause he's up there he's been
promoting it what do you make of this
route how do you think it ends
well we'll find out in the long run but
i beg greg norman to let me be on the
live tour because
you know
we work really hard and i play with
brian harmon and practice around and
some other guys in the practice rounds
of the
british open it's like we play pro-ams
we get it okay that's what is the
backbone of a lot of our tournaments but
brian harmon says give us a box of
chocolates for the effort
we make tent visits we do this we do
that i play two to three programs every
week on the champions tour
and you know we don't play for a lot of
money on the champions tour so i almost
feel like okay i'm not getting a lot out
of this
what what what are we doing look i'd
rather play with amber's than the pro
sometimes but
you know we've got to get compensated
for that and the live tour has given
players that
it's given you know they play pro-ams
it's a big party they play for a lot of
money which these guys that are on that
tour deserve that money and i think
there's a lot of other guys that deserve
that money especially this old man
what about the reality issue because i i
think and i wrote this for the new york
post there's a lot of hypocrisy about
morality in sport but a lot of the pga
sponsors for example do lots of business
in the middle east and so on uh do you
think there's a lot of hypocrisy here
oh pierce let's not talk about that they
don't want to be mentioned in that
because you know of all the labor laws
and stuff you know what i'm saying it's
unbelievable the politics is so stupid
in this i could talk about nike i could
talk about other companies that little
eight and 13 year olds are building
shoes for nike okay we don't want to get
into that right you want to talk about
labor laws we're talking about golf
guys that are playing golf it's an
international sport
jed the prince
of saudi arabia is a great guy
and he's given so much money
to golfers that deserve it
well there's some that aren't deserving
because i should be on that tour yeah
why aren't you on the tour you'll be my
first time you know all the ben
well greg says he's not doing any more
and i'm too old so
but let me go into entertainment and get
all my get all my friends do the
concerts and stuff and let's you know
it's
playing with bryce in shamble in the
british open i'm sorry the open
championship i can't say british anymore
but
uh was an eye-opener because he said
it's the greatest thing on earth we
still play a pro-am
it's two pros
two amateurs yeah it's what it should be
anyway you're done in four hours yeah
and we played for a lot of money which
we deserve to play for
but
you know i just wish
to sum this up i wish
every tour would get along where
everything can work out i think that you
know what darth vader is such a great
game i think that's the way it's going
to go they're going to have to do a deal
because so many top players are
defecting they're going to not have a
pga tour at this rate talk to me about
donald trump for a moment uh he's an old
friend of yours uh old friend of mine um
what do you make of him what do you
think about him running again for
president would you endorse them
daddy trump is the greatest president we
ever had i go back to the reagan era and
bush senior
what he did
with kind of a downfall of presidency
with obama nothing against obama but
daddy trump came in and what i love
about him
he said
everything that he was going to do
unfortunately the biden administration
did the opposite of what they said they
were going to do our country is in
shambles our middle class people are
starving they're not doing anything for
them and it just makes me sick
kamala hair is supposed to protect the
border she's been down there she went to
el paso to have drinks and a mexican
food
it's it saddens me
that
the way this administration is the whole
white house is so corrupt right now it's
all about them making money and we'll
worry about the american people later
donald trump never took a dime from the
american people never took a salary and
is one of the best presidents that ever
lived john we call this show piers
morgan on censor for a reason because we
like uncensored guests you are an
uncensored guest great to talk to you
thank you very much
i love you and what you did for the
queen's jubilee
i couldn't take my eyes off the tv
your knowledge of her was so amazing in
the family thank you for that because i
got a new i got a new opening to
what the queen of royalty was all about
that's brilliant princess diane was
still alive i'd be
i would be married to her
[Laughter]
john great to talk to you all the very
best to you
thank you see you buddy
well that's almost over tonight and in
fact that's almost all for me uh because
we've done 14 weeks on the show and i'm
off to take a restful break interviewing
serial killers in maximum security
prisons in rural america jeremy kyle
will be borrowing my desk from next
monday he's not the best choice but he
was the only one that was available
that's a joke he's great the show will
go on and i'm sure you agree it's been a
pretty extraordinary first few months we
started with nurse shadowing interview
making headlines around the world and
that's how we've ended this first run
and i'll be back
only a fool would think that was a
legitimate you become a full
i do now yeah let it roll hi margarita
have you lived up to every dream that
little boy had i have to say pretty much
well i like to tell it as it is yeah i'm
not influenced by the media yeah but
they are very seriously influenced by me
yes
you triggered my aging anxiety
i'm prepared to take that to your
therapist are you interviewing me or am
i interviewing you i'm not doing all the
talking
i'm now going to have the great honor
of officially i'm canceling you to the
world it was um stated that elvis you
know
uh with um a racist he's never been a
racist happy
birthday
mr morgan
how do you confirm or deny it this is
your facebook page can you see the
likeness i didn't put that picture on
your profile page yeah but you've chosen
to spend two or three minutes of this
interview talking about an irrelevant
the guy's been doing the same
effort part for 35 years everybody knows
american pie but if everybody that knows
that song came to my shows i'd be
selling out stadiums kind of only came
on here because i thought it would be
kind of funny but i want to say
i apologize again to all uh viewers who
listen to that i've rumbled you kim
kardashian have you ever actually eaten
that vegan gruel you just take in the
cash how about if you do fight again you
have to give me a million pounds how
about that's a deal
boris johnson must go the greased piglet
of politics has slipped and squirmed
through almost three disastrous years
boris johnson is out your english is
better than my ukrainian yes that's the
show that's true
[Laughter]
i was not laughing so much so loud
well we have some fun we've got some
more farming back in september when we
have a new british prime minister on my
first day back to stick my teeth into
until then whatever you're up to this
summer just keep it unsensitive good
night
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers allen in brisbane
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson rishi
sunak said inflation is the number one
challenge facing the country while is
trust veg to deliver the northern
powerhouse rail in the first official
hustings of the leadership campaign
tonight the pair vying to become the
next prime minister made their pitch to
tory party members in leeds
the controversial tavistock gender
identity clinic will close following a
recent review describing this as not a
safe option for children and teenagers
the clinic the only one of its kind in
the uk has been accused of rushing
children into life-altering treatment on
puberty blockers
and the 22nd commonwealth games is
underway in birmingham prince charles
kicked off the opening ceremony this
evening in the queen's place 72 nations
will compete in 280 medal events over
the next 11 days that's all for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign